deux élèves de parcours florian au lycée
choiseul et lili au collège ronsard
ce qui pourrait sembler banal pour
d'autres et pour eux plus difficile en
tant qu enfant handicapé il bénéficie de
la présence d'un adulte accompagnant
depuis le cp à sa naissance florian a
manqué d'oxygène infirmes moteurs pour
lui aller à l'école a nécessité des
aménagements
tu viens plus rien on va regarder des
photos ouais j'ai trouvé des photos de
tous à l'école ses parents se sont
battus pour qu'il aille dans une école
normale
le 30 mai le plus tes copains et copines
quand on est arrivé ici on est beaucoup
de mal parce que déjà n'y avait pas eu
d'enfants handicapés à l'école
les veaux qu'une structure rien près
même pas une rampe d'accès pour un
fauteuil rien du tout on était presque
exclu de l'école à cause de sa mère qui
dessine donc d'un ménage vais pas le
dire
c'est à l'école j'étais souvent insulter
donc c'est pour ça que c'est
principalement ce même collège tout
répond pierre parce que pour mémoire
assez ne sait percer
[Musique]
plus d'un habitant sur deux
sur la terre un habitant sur deux
habitants dit florian a besoin d'un
accompagnement toute la journée
il est suivi à temps plein par deux
auxiliaires de vie scolaire ce matin
c'est le jour de carol il est il est pas
plus loin dans la réflexion qu'un autre
élève parce qu'il s'est passé un gamin
qui est même super intelligent mais ça
lui demande plus de temps de oued de
réflexion et de concentration c'est un
petit peu plus long à démarrer
c'est moins que le mot alors le ce livre
le soit calomniée qu'est ce que ça
signifie
c'est donc en son absence et on en fait
justement je pense de temps en temps
l'oublier cet handicap
même si parfois ça revient au grand
galop dans une manière de prendre les
cours la manière de travailler avec les
lèvres et d'élèves à se concentrer à se
reconcentrer à bien comprendre la
consigne que l'enseignant demande à 12
ans lily est en sixième faute
d'auxiliaire elle a redoublé son cp
atteinte de ce que l'on nomme un trouble
invisible une sorte de dysphasie
il lui est impossible de retranscrire
certains sont sans claire l'école est un
calvaire pour elle vous êtes communes
comme l'ange gardien de lille i un peu
comme un jeu peut-être des fois
peut-être un peu trop sur elle mais moi
je veux qu'elle rêve enfin su que le
qu'elles réussissent donc je regarde
tout ce qu'elle fait des fois je
mangeais safe à ce qu'il faut c'est
aussi lui donner de l'autonomie donc
c'est bon on prend aussi des distances
regardez bien tu as déjà te regarder
celle ci elle est la fête du droit après
son malaise aussi et il va bientôt se
mettre au dessus
alors justement pourquoi tu peux le
tourner c'est une sacrée charge de
travail qu'on leur donne de sacrés
responsabilité et au quotidien je pense
qu'effectivement d'être tout le temps
l'a rabâché à l'expliquer ça demande une
énergie folle en cm2 lily devait
intégrer un établissement spécialisé
mais ses parents ont bataillé pour qu'on
leur accorde une chance au collège
lily est suivi depuis six ans par claire
la même auxiliaire de vie
un accompagnement idéal mais un cas
quasi unique dans l'éducation nationale
clerc mais plusieurs codes couleurs ce
qui met des ont passé plus de temps sur
un exercice
voilà t notes se sont mises à remonter
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pathé que j'ai
clairement bah oui sans remonter vers
lui a surtout appris à avoir confiance
en elle et c'est ce qui manque est
élevée c'est d'avoir lu avoir appris la
confiance en lui faisant confiance
elle explique annick elle lui faisait
confiance qu'elle ne doutait pas ses
capacités que elle elle était là
justement pour l'aider à développer ses
capacités et d'arriver à travailler tout
seul ici la famille à des kits
pédagogiques travaillent ensemble
l'école s'adapte à l'enfant
avant c'était les enfants qui devaient
s'adapter à l'école et ce malgré cette
loi sur l'éducation du 30 juin 1975
attendu depuis de longs mois le projet
de loi en faveur des handicapés et
présentait ce matin l'assemblée
nationale par rené lenoir secrétaire
d'état à l'action sociale
une loi peut appliquer sur les deux cent
mille enfants à peine 10% étaient
intégrés dans des écoles dites normales
en 1995 en indre et loire face à un
problème d'intégration
josé puig à leur inspecteur d'académie
fait appel à mireille malot présidente
d'handicap conseils pour recruter des
accompagnants scolaires ailleurs à
marseille dans la sarthe
les associations se fédèrent c'est la
naissance des auxiliaires de vie
alors c'est qu'on s'était dans les tous
débuts on a créé alizés lac élèves
romands relance en 1997 quand la loi sur
les emplois jeunes passent le de l'eau
se précipitent chez le préfet pour
recruter les parents étaient là en
disant nous on est dans un département
où il n'ya pas d'association
c'est pas normal que nos enfants n'aient
pas les mêmes droits que dans le
département des conneries donc très vite
il ya eu cette montée en charge qui a
créé cette pression pour que le système
devienne un système accessible de tous
les départements du territoire national
les parents déménagent et en indre et
loire pour pouvoir scolariser dans la
mare feuilles souviens c'était 7 et
délirant en quatre ans il embauche plus
de 80 auxiliaire en juillet 2001
mireille malot remet son rapport à jack
lang ministre de l'éducation nationale
vingt propositions pour pérenniser le
dispositif la légitimité de mireille
c'est pas parce que c'était une experte
ce n'est pas une technocrate de
qui avait l'habitude de parler la langue
de bois des ministères c'était quelqu'un
qui était sur le terrain qu'ils savaient
sur le terrain ce que représentait pour
des parents d'un enfant handicapé
le fait de se voir refuser l'accès en
janvier 2003 63 associations de parents
réclament la professionnalisation des
auxiliaires de vie scolaire le
dispositif associatif on arrête on passe
le relais à l'état donc à l'éducation
nationale on est confiant on a démontré
sur le terrain c'était possible après le
système associatif a ses limites c'est
normal que l'éducation nationale
s'empare de cette question ces enfants
là ils vont à l'école ordinaire comme
les autres
magali est l'une des premières
auxiliaires embauché par l'association
de mireille malot
elle a exercé pendant douze ans
maintenant il travaille dans une crèche
magali si j'ai si je l'aurais pas je ne
serais pas dans cette crise là ça c'est
clair et net que tu serais ou alors je
serai peut-être en train de redoubler
peut-être même avec mes talons quand on
est passé de d'associatifs à l'éducation
nationale on avait moins d'heures auprès
des enfants
donc c'est assez compliqué à gérer pour
nous dans le suivi et pour les élèves
parce que
j'ai même eu des enfants myopathes qui
n'avaient pas plainte en emploi
solidarité contrats aidés un turnover
s'instaure pour magali l'éducation
nationale n'a pas joué le jeu
le fait d'avoir augmenter le nombre et
d'avoir recruté à tout va alors qu'il
n'ya pas de formation initiale forcément
ça se dégrade sur la fonction d'avs et s
pour connaître les diverses handicap on
va pas travailler avec un enfant
trisomique comme on va travailler avec
un enfant autiste la dure beaucoup 20h 1
600 euros banon je veux dire c'est pas
possible
quand on a une fin même seul français
pas possible avec un loyer c'est pas
possible
[Musique]
pour l'instant la vs est une fonction
pas un métier certains chercheurs en
sciences de l'éducation pense l'élargir
au périscolaire
d'autres sont persuadés que l'auxiliaire
devrait être affectée à un seul
établissement
il y a des enfants qui sont handicapés
mais qui n'ont pas de besoins
particuliers réciproquement il y a des
enfants qu'ils n'ont pas de handicap et
qui sont en grande difficulté dans
l'école beaucoup d'accompagnement ne
tiennent pas au fait d'être handicapé ou
non handicapés mais à voix médiane au
fait d'avoir des besoins particuliers
donc nous sommes nombreux en éducation à
promouvoir l'idée du besoin particulier
est de faire en sorte que les
dispositifs d'adaptation que l'on va
mettre en place soit des dispositifs qui
soit utile bien au delà du handicap à
tous les enfants qui en ont besoin
grâce à claire lilly a repris confiance
en elle à l'école et en sport aussi elle
est vice-championne régionale de
gymnastique
oui
auxiliaire de vie scolaire un vrai
métier ou pas aujourd'hui c'est une
fonction qui recouvre des réalités
extrêmement diverses avec des problèmes
de cloisonnement un manque de formation
de tous les acteurs de l'éducation
nationale certaines avs déplore le
manque de reconnaissance
on a une bonne relation que le
professeur le l'éducation nationale en
général quoi savoir dans un temps qui
prennent de nouvelles pour savoir ce que
ça va ça se passe bien tout simplement
voilà plus de communication entre nous
et peut-être l'administratif ou où les
référents qui sont qui s'occupe des avs
il ya passé des changes et voilà on se
sent parfois un peu isolé un peu seul
c'est qu'elles sont autour de quoi ils
sont plutôt dans londres à l'extérieur
de long dans la banlieue de long florian
est bien intégrée à l'école et ça va de
mieux en mieux
pourtant entre la 3e et la seconde il a
failli être orientés vers un lycée
professionnel
même avec ces bons résultats il doit se
battre pour rester dans un cursus normal
dès qu'il rentre le soir il se vide la
tête devant des jeux vidéo
plus tard il aimerait les concevoir et
c'est bien parti
on peut toujours faire mieux que ce
qu'on fait je vais bosser sur des trucs
c'est un jeu mais je peux toujours
permis
[Musique]
avec florian et délits les élèves
découvrent que la différence est une
richesse
il ne les considèrent plus uniquement
par leur handicap
quand ces élèves vont dans la même école
que les autres on parle d'inclusion
scolaire une inclusion scolaire réussie
c'est l'école de la vie
elle permet de répondre aux
transformations de la société
oui